If you're watching this
on your daily commute,
you'd be forgiven for feeling
less than enthusiastic about trains.
But as hard as it is to imagine,
before the advent of commuter rail
people faced a lot more peril than
indefinite delays, expensive fares
and getting to know the intimate
notes of strangers' body odours.
The world's first purpose-built
passenger railway opened in 1830
and ran between
Liverpool and Manchester.
Prior to that, if you wanted
to travel between the two
you would either have to spend 12
hours meandering along the canals,
which wasn’t so bad if you
were willing to shut your eyes
and pretend you were in Venice,
or you could risk a three hour
bone-jolting stagecoach ride
down narrow, winding roads
and keeping everything crossed
that you wouldn't crash!
The new trains reached speeds
of up to 35mph.
While some thrill seeking passengers
treated the experience
like a day at Alton Towers,
others were terrified by the speed.
An early passenger,
Charles Young, said:
Nobody tell Charles about
the Shanghai maglev,
which with speeds
of up to 267.8mph,
is the fastest train in the world.
It's hard to imagine how impressive
this new invention was
to early adopters.
Actress Fanny Kemble described
the romanticism of it:
You might find it comforting that
one thing that hasn't changed
is that the railway company
underestimated the demand
for their magical machine.
Having budgeted for
a daily quota of 250 passengers,
the railway regularly
found itself carrying
more than four times that many.
One thing us modern commuters
should perhaps be grateful for,
although first class passengers
on the early trains
had covered carriages, everyone
else was exposed to the elements.
At least now we all get a roof!
We can also count ourselves lucky
to have official stops and platforms.
At first, stops were by request but
that quickly became inconvenient.
You can probably guess why.
And with no raised platforms,
passengers boarded
the train at track level.
Definitely not a risk
you'd take today.
While the rail network wasn't
and still isn't perfect,
it's easy to forget just how
revolutionary it actually was.
The easy journey between
Manchester and Liverpool
meant people could more effectively
meet and do business,
had new opportunities for leisure
and maybe even to find love.
Knowledge and ideas could
also be communicated
more quickly than ever before,
with the transportation
of newspapers and mail.
As the rail network grew, more
accurate time-keeping was needed
to keep travellers on track.
Clocks around the country were
synchronised and standardised,
and railway time ruled.
This ensured that
six o'clock in Oxford
was the same as in Crewe and Barrow.
So whether you love or hate
rail travel,
there's no denying
that life in the UK today
would be unimaginable without it.
And the next time you've got
your nose in someone's armpit,
think back to a time when
commuter rail was an exciting,
magical and even terrifying
new technology.
You might just see it
in a whole new light.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)